well i think i suppose since i stopped
doing drugs and drinking i think
probably uh
i i i really prize getting up early in
the morning
which is something that happens um i now
find
for years now i've gotten up regularly
at six in the morning
it doesn't matter what time i go to bed
i still get up which is not a great
thing actually when i'm rehearsing
because you rehearse
pretty late but i still get up at six i
enjoyed the fact of seeing the light
come up with me
and then utilizing the daylight and what
it brings and the kind of message that
it brings
it's a different message from when
you're living in twilight hours and
things get very
symbolic representationally if you live
through the twilight hours and
the early hours of the morning you
there's some kind of there's a shadow to
your life all the time
psychologically you're in the dark as
well as physically in the dark
there's something that i find very
uplifting and uh
optimistic and creative about working
and being
very much in the daylight